l'importance majeure
de d'avoir ce rappel de vaccination
alors je suis prudent
c'est à dire que j'entends parfois que
la vaccination contre le coc vide ce
sont deux injections plus un rappel
et moi je vous dis aujourd'hui que je ne
sais pas
pour l'instant c'est un rappel
mais peut-être qu'il en faudra un
quatrième ça je ne sais pas si j'ai
personnellement été comme jamais été
vacciné très tôt j'ai eu mon rappel
mi-septembre somme tout j'ai pas regardé
mais je ne sais pas si au bout de trois
mois l'a pratiquement au bout de trois
mois où on a eu mon immunité c'est à
dire combien de temps va durer le
rappelle est un point important qui est
je pense qu'il faut qu'on dise dans une
crise de ce type qu'on dise tout ce
qu'on sait et qu'on le mette sur la
table pour qu'on partage ce conseil ou
ce qu'on ne sait pas donc il est
possible que nous ayons besoin et bien à
un moment donné d'une quatrième dose
pour rappeler et dans quels délais je ne
le sais pas encore il est possible aussi
et c'est important que compte tenu de ce
facteur joue zi 2,7 ou 2,8 à 10 du boost
qui était donné par la troisième dose le
bush soit tellement important qu'il soit
durable dans le temps puisqu'on en a
changé des mots on est passé quasiment
un lob au dessus entre entre le type de
réponse immunitaire
[Musique]